and now for something completely
different we talked about aliens earlier
say uh george brought up bob lazar i i
um
we'll likely probably talk to bob lazar
on this podcast and then um
and then john had a skeptical look on
his face about about aliens so let me
ask uh john and gordon
uh do you think there's intelligent
alien civilizations out there in the
universe outside of our own the universe
is unimaginably large the idea that we
are the only life forms in a cosmos as
large as this
is
i think naive and foolish
um
there's a very high likelihood that if
life could evolve on this planet that it
could have done so on many many other
planets around the uh around the cosmos
i think anyone who puts even a moment's
thought into this would realize that
there's
almost certainly other forms of life out
there
the real question with regards the alien
community is um have they got here and
now they surfing our planet
in um little silver sources and
making observations and periodically
stealing people
for experimentation purposes doesn't
have to be silver saucers it could be
different other color saucers um and
that question i'm i'm i'm not at all
convinced no i i didn't
recently um navy footage
has come out showing
some very interesting phenomena if you
talk to almost any experienced pilot
they will tell you they've seen things
in the upper atmosphere that are very
difficult to explain
i'll be the first one to agree with you
on this there are some things out there
that are extremely difficult to explain
like literally ufos unidentified yeah i
mean we just don't know what they are
but to go from the idea that there's
things out there that we don't
understand to
this
like
little creatures running around and um
and these somehow exist uh
i just reserve judgment i just say i'm
agnostic about these things i think it's
possible but um all the evidence that
i've been shown so far was insufficient
to come to any kind of definite
conclusions until
aliens land in central park on tuesday
afternoon at 3 pm and get out with
little alien ray guns and start shooting
people i didn't believe in
many of the stories that get told
well what about if it's not little
aliens with ray guns but something very
different very very difficult to detect
for us humans that's very human creature
at that point it's a it's a fascinating
idea and it's certainly possible but
show me the evidence
all right what about you gordon
do you do you uh look at the cosmos and
ponder the stars
often i think it's a fair points john
raised
something really interesting i saw the
other day was uh
someone posted like
if an alien organ or civilization
65 million light years away somehow
managed to look
at earth
they would theoretically see the
dinosaurs because they're 65 million
light years away so like imagine us
looking at
galaxies that are 100 million light
years away that's 100 million years ago
you have no idea what it looks like now
so that's super interesting to me about
it
yeah the the expanse is huge
and so much cool stuff could be going
out there
the scary thing of course is if they
haven't visited us yet
the
there has to be a good reason for it
and the the set of scary reasons of all
the fact that they maybe once you get
sufficiently advanced in your
development you destroy yourself
naturally as humans seem to be
approaching now
we more and more have the tools to
destroy ourselves completely
in terms of our weapon systems
um and we're developing them more and
more and they're becoming better and
better
and then we're starting to get angry and
angry on twitter and instagram with each
other it's those are good points you're
raising
history has taught us that
everything that lives one day will die
so we will we will perish one day yeah
there's also just the the sheer
difficulty of um
of
of travel through space like space is an
unimaginably inhospitable environment
and to the best of our knowledge
this even the theoretical speeds that we
can attain in space even if we could
travel at the speed of light we're not
even remotely close to that
still the distances that need to be
traveled to get to even relatively close
solar systems are
very very long if you look at astronauts
who have spent significant amounts of
time and space just orbiting the earth
it has severe health effects on them
which is not built for space we're
supposed to be
in a gravitational environment